so will you be using your new studio um
to work on the Chuck reboot because we
heard the reboot what might happen like
a movie like hi listen did you guys want
more Chuck
[Music]
so I know right look at that baby just a
baby I know but it's so cool this is I
mean it's such a cult following yeah
Chuck like I mean I'm telling you I know
what masses would come to see this
listen I've been trying for years I okay
I was trying to make a Chuck move even
before we finished making the TV show I
I'm getting closer okay I'm getting
closer
the pressure
um no look Josh Schwartz and Chris fedak
who were the writer creators of the show
they're on board I just got to get the
powers that be meaning uh the folks at
Warner Brothers uh television and film
to kind of help you know let's let's put
this thing together but all the cast is
all ready to go everybody's ready to go
we just need a script and we need the
the money and and the slides and yeah
for it but because here's the thing
though you have leverage because we all
want it yeah exactly so do it so do it
you heard it Kelly said do it so do it
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]